many people feel powerless to do
anything about climate change because
they think maybe it's too late
oil and gas industries online shopping
addictions and Caribbean vacations are
pumping our atmosphere so full of co2
that the oceans are dying sea levels are
rising species are disappearing and
massive droughts floods fires and
snowpocalypse a''s are making it really
hard to plan your outfit in the morning
what is it really too late to prevent an
ecological end of days the short answer
is almost we're in what climate
scientists and activists are referring
to as decade zero which basically means
unless we make major changes today our
window for preventing environmental
collapse is going to close we're facing
a crisis we've never faced before
both crisis comes opportunity like the
chance to build a future based on living
in balance with the earth and one
another sound to hit before you well as
James Hansen a former NASA director once
said either we will change our ways and
build an entirely new kind of global
society or they will be changed for us
drastic yes
but realistic when looking at the
science humans have already caused the
globe to warm by one degree Celsius and
we're on track to potentially exceed
four degrees in as little as a hundred
years we're already seeing the effects
extreme weather mass extinctions food
and water shortages but four degrees
hotter means goodbye civilization hello
apocalypse as depressing as it all
sounds it's not time to Netflix and bury
our heads in the sand it's time to get
our asses in gear
if we stop polluting today and when I
say stop I mean stop burning fossil
fuels we could potentially limit warming
to just over 2 degrees Celsius which
would go a long way in avoiding utter
planetary collapse but even then rising
sea levels could threaten 15 of the
world's 20 largest cities including New
York Miami Tokyo and Mumbai
the real problem is our modern
industrialized way of life depends on an
abusive relationship to the earth over
fish over farm clear-cut extract and
expand we depend on destructive fossil
fuels for things that we need but also
things that we don't we're killing
ourselves with convenience and the
planet literally can't take it so what
do we do
multinationals and world leaders are
relying on the same industries and
economics that got us into this mess to
try and get us out
they push carbon offsets cap-and-trade
and green technology but these so-called
solutions are riddled with problems take
carbon offsetting for example a company
like an airline can essentially
greenwash its image by planting some
trees or buying some solar panels
without ever significantly reducing its
emissions plus these so-called solutions
don't actually get us off a path of
consumerist earth plundering economics
and what's the point of solar and wind
energy if they're just letting us watch
the walking dead on our brand new iPhone
15 s's our very way of life needs
restructuring a transition from
exploitation to preservation which means
our behavior is going to have to
radically change it sounds like a lot I
know
luckily some people are already on it
communities around the world are
organizing and fighting to protect their
land water and air activists in
southeast Montana are working to keep
billions of tons of coal in the ground
cities and states are banning fracking
and thousands of people mobilized to
successfully get President Obama to
block the Keystone XL pipeline of course
individual action to reduce your carbon
footprint like not getting your toilet
paper airmail to your front door helps
but it's going to take more than that
so maybe the question isn't is it too
late but at what point is each of us
step up is that when the oceans become
an acidic soup of plastic or when there
are no more wild elephants or Tigers or
cute manatees or when a storm wipes out
your entire city what's your limit